today
yep are we allowed to stay in and vote
on that
welcome everyone to the meeting of the
northeast derbyshire district council
cabinet
uh i'll start by just notifying everyone
that we are
under fairly uncharted territory at the
moment we've had a
major i.t malfunction which has meant
that
um cabinet members aren't able to access
their papers so we're having to
do our very best so i hope that you'll
be able to bear with us
uh in introducing the papers uh to the
best of our ability
um i'll start with apologies for absence
we have
uh apologies from uh mark foster council
mark foster
and councillor jeremy kenyon uh i don't
believe there are any others to record
now are there any declarations of
interest from any members
um councillor charlotte cupert and i
would like to record that
although we were previously on the
written homes limited board
we have both now resigned so there is a
paper later on that deals with some
housing issues
but that we no longer have an interest
in those
in that in that issue so we are able to
stay in the meeting and vote
at that stage um okay we'll move on to
the minute to the last meeting
has everyone had a chance to read them
and can confirm that they're a
true and accurate record
thank you all in favor raise your hand
please thank you
okay and then we come to the
corporate plan targets performance
update so this relates to quarter four
of our first year of administration but
when we were still adopting the
the previous administration's corporate
plan
so i'll hand over to kath if you're okay
cath just to give us a short
summary of the report if that's okay
no that's absolutely fine so as you've
just said this is the last
uh quarterly performance of the
transitional targets that were brought
over for
1920 um so just really by summary you'll
see
from the report that all the targets
have been achieved apart from a few that
were affected by covid
in that last quarter so a largely
positive report
quite a few of the targets will be are
still targets under the new council plan
and will continue to be monitored
so we won't lose sight of some of these
things that have run through the council
for some time so
it's just really to complete the record
and it's there for
public consumption uh that it's largely
been
successful the targets which is
obviously great for officers and members
concerned it's been a
team effort in getting these targets
achieved obviously
towards the end of march it's getting
more difficult with some of the targets
with kovid and that will obviously
reflect
us so in the q1 report going forward but
we'll clearly reference that in the
report so members are aware of that
thank you kat for that so obviously the
next uh the next q1 report will be based
on the new council plan
and the new um targets and uh and
and kpis etc it will so we'll we'll
start to do the formal recording of that
through the cabinet
uh every quarter so that'll be
obviously more relevant and more
interest to people going forward but
this just closes uh for audit purposes
the last uh council plan
transition yeah brilliant okay thank you
for that cap
any other comments or questions from
uh cabinet members yeah
if not are we happy to i'm happy to move
the recommendations do i have a
second four sectors
for myself we'll consider that moved
um okay thank you for that so
uh next paper uh is the medium term
financial plan
budget monitoring report april to june
2020 quarter one report so i'll hand
over to you
for to take us through this paper thank
you very much
thank you very much chair uh yeah this
is the uh
medium term financial plan budget
monitoring
uh for april uh slightly delayed but um
not uh not terribly so uh and i think
the best thing to do is actually if
uh since i uh will struggle to see the
papers and having all the papers in
front of me
other than what's on screen i think i'll
ask officer dethick just to uh
talk us through this one
okay over to you jay thank you
if only i could turn my microphone on
i'd be happy to do that i'm sorry about
that delay
yeah just just briefly to run this
through i think i think a lot of you are
aware of these issues because i've been
bringing updates
prior to this quarter one update covered
19's had quite an impact on
on on quarter one um we are entering the
recovery phase we are starting to get
some um
normality i would like to say back into
delivery of our services
and we're keen to get some stability
back into the budget for this year so
we're hoping to bring the
revised budget to october's meeting
so we can get budget holders back taking
some control of their budgets and then
try and get a little bit more normality
back into the system
and we've received 1.2 million pounds
worth of grants from
from the government so far um which
we've put into the resilience reserve to
protect
against the costs of covid we've also
received some additional information
just this week from mhclg which is
advised that we're going to also benefit
from the income loss scheme which
looks like we're going to get some
support for our leisure centers after
the first five percent
it seems and the devil's always in the
detail with these things but it seems
that we're going to get 75 pence in
every pound of the difference between
our budget and income
and our actual income as a result of
covid which almost sounds too good to be
true so we'll
we'll watch this space and what the
detail says but that will be um
incredibly helpful cash flow was a bit
of a consensus at the outset but it's
held up really really well
and getting the advanced payments of
government grants and there is the
deferred payments on the business rates
has helped us a lot
we're going to keep a close eye on this
because i think there's a lot of
speculation that once the fairly scheme
ends we may end up
with more difficulties with cash
collection but currently council tax is
only 1.4
below where we were this time last year
which is which is remarkable
in considering the circumstances that
we're operating in
um business rates is not faring quite so
well that's 86
where we forecast 98 last year so a
little bit more of a concern with
business rates as you'd probably expect
everything else is holding its own fees
and charges um
although as you'd expect in the
activity-based um services such as
leisure
but planning fees um trade waste and
industrial units are all holding up
relatively well so it's quite a
quite an optimistic feature that we're
painting at the moment
and in terms of the overall position
with the general fund it's almost
it's almost on budget we should expect
because we did an emergency budget for
covid only a couple of months ago so
we're only 132k adrift majority of
that's within income
and again mainly planning fees nothing
really made you to report
on on that one the hra's not really been
affected by covid that's pretty stable
and the capital programme is um
obviously under at the moment because we
paused a lot of the activity which we're
now starting to
release the restrictions on that in a
cautious manner
appendix 4 just goes through some
treasury management activity doesn't
really
um give you a great deal of additional
information on what you normally receive
not really affecting the treasury
management position because the cash
flows held that could have been quite a
different position but
it's not so i'm happy to take any
questions before i move back to
councillor parking to move the
recommendation
okay thank you jane for that any
questions from from members
for officers for that matter oh caroline
i can see your hand raising
yeah um yeah well done um
jane and team uh obviously very
difficult circumstances
um although there's been some quite
significant
financial package for uh business
particularly
and um whilst a lot of businesses are
weather in the storm
has there been anything from government
in terms of projections because i think
next year when the support's not there
is when we're going to have our
perhaps more severe issues um and i was
interested to know if
if any of that discussion had taken
place through any government channels
through your chair not as yet councillor
renek i've not heard anything about what
they're planning for next year of course
the business rates holiday is the big
one
that'll be the really interesting one is
to see whether this they extend that for
different areas of the sector and again
for the retail and hospitality sector
because
although the grant was nice i think the
business rates holiday is much more
helpful because it lasts for the
duration of this financial year so
we've not heard anything as yet um but
as soon as i do i will let you know
brilliant thank you jane any other
questions for jane
if not i'll hand back to you paul to uh
to summarize and move recommendations
thank you chair yes i'd like to move
recommendations uh in section six higher
six point one in this case
uh that uh cabinet knows the budget
budget monitoring position airline is
reported
i'll i'll second and then we can move to
the boat
thank you all those in favor
yeah okay that's carried thank you very
much
and then we move on to the uh
financial outcome paper for 20 19 20.
so over to you paul again then
what do you want to go straight to jane
thank you very much
yeah this is the uh slightly delayed but
not too much uh
financial out turn um and uh i i will
leave it to jane to
uh uh to give you the detail on this
as i say we're struggling with some
mighty problems at the moment but
um yes if you would chair thank you
thank you to you jane
thank you chair thank you councillor
parking yes as council parking says this
is the financial outcome position from
the 31st of march which is a little bit
delayed but
i have to say i was delighted to be able
to produce the accounts by the 17th of
june my team worked incredibly hard
under very difficult circumstances to
get them done only two weeks later than
the statutory deadline so
it was um it was challenging at times
but we got there in the end so
and mazzars have been auditing us and
this was i put that they were obviously
over the past three weeks which was
three weeks ago but it still
seems to be ongoing but um they've had a
few stuffing issues i think so
that i spoke to the audit manager just
last week and he's not reported
any major issues and they're looking at
something around pensions but that's a
national issue as opposed to a local
issue to us so
i'm just waiting to hear whether that
will need a change to the accounts which
if it does we'll will amend those before
they go to the audit committee on the
30th of september
and in terms of the actual out turn
position appendix two
appendix one and appendix two shows the
general composition
we were 147 000 pounds on dispense which
have moved to the resilience reserve
um as was agreed in the mtfp the main
variances
are our pay which is predominantly
vacancy savings
um and ndr ndr's below budget because we
couldn't
we couldn't forecast any growth at the
point of producing the accounts because
the derbyshire pool hadn't been settled
and the nndr3 was delayed
and we've generally taken the view
across the pool that we're not going to
amend this years because it creates
quite a lot of work for the
administrative body at derby city
council
so i think we're all going to stick with
our position and make the adjustments
in in the following year which the
auditors are all happy with so
it just saves a little bit of um
confusion with changing the accounts of
such a late stage
we've got three budgets that we need to
roll over into the new financial year
there's eleven thousand pound for moist
which was due to a delay in the supply
chain
there was seventeen and a half thousand
pound for some remedial works that are
needed
at wingworth lido which we didn't finish
in 1920 which we're going to continue to
do in 2021
and then there was a health and safety
um training budget that the
health and safety team just couldn't um
organize in time for the end of the
financial year
um reserves in and out totaling 1.9
million and 1.2 that's all detailed in
1.7 and 1.8
i won't go through those in too much
detail but i'll be happy to take any
questions
hra very few variances again we
contributed
an underspend of 304 000 to the
development reserve which is great
because that can invest in future
projects and the hra balance at 3
million is
um retained the capital programme was
underspent
and but as is the norm with the capital
programme we are rolling those balances
over and there's a recommendation at 6.3
should you choose to support it to do so
um happy to take any questions and then
move back to counselor parking for 6.1
to 6.3 to be moved
thank you uh jane uh any questions from
members
just to echo um carolyn's words during
the last paper to
of thanks to to you jane and your team
uh for the incredible amounts of hard
work you've had to go through in
uh in almost radically redefining the
budget overnight
uh to be able to to allow us to cope
with the pressures and strains of
kobed uh and also in terms of getting
the the statutory accounts
uh done so quickly so so well done to
all of your team
uh i'll hand over then to paul to uh to
move the recommendations
thank you very much chair um yes and uh
and then just an extra note there and
the
when we when we took some uh rather
stringent actions
on spending for the covid um
budget that we uh implemented
the knock-on effect of that was a
significant amount of extra work for
uh for the staff within the finance
department
uh and um we're we're very very grateful
for everybody's efforts in in the
department
uh so yes i'd like to move
recommendations
6.1 6.2 and 6.3 please
yeah i'm happy to second that again um
all those in favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
if we could just go back to the agenda
amy
because i'll need to read out the um
the uh the final bits um
so are there any uh urgent items
uh i don't believe i have any on my on
my radar
um exclusion in the press and public uh
i move that the public be excluded from
the meeting
during the discussion uh of the
following items of business to avoid the
disclosure
to them of exempt information as defined
in part one
of schedule 12a of the local government
act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
uh so i move that the public be excluded
and can we confirm that the
um the live stream has been stopped
just check for you chat thank you
[Music]
you